Speaker 1: Well, Donald Trump appears to have
admitted to a major crime during his latest
childish tantrum, insane meltdown, the equivalent
of, I don't know, a little kid pooping in the
sandbox because it's time to go home. Donald Trump
has now alleged that he helped Ron DeSantis in his
2018 election by sending in the FBI to do what?
It's not even clear clearly some kind of election
interference. This you absolutely have to see
Trump posting on his platform. Truth, social.
Speaker 4: Troth, essential.
Speaker 1: Quote. I also fixed his campaign,
which had completely fallen apart. I was all in
for Ron and he beat Gillum. But after the race,
race is capitalized. We don't know why.
You never know why. But after the race,
when votes were being stolen by the corrupt
capital e election process in Broward County
and Ron was going down 10,000 votes a
day, along with now Senator Rick Scott,
I sent in the FBI and the U.S. attorneys and
the ballot theft immediately ended just prior
to them running out of the votes necessary to
win. I stopped his election from being stolen.
Trump did what? Trump sent in the FBI to. To
do what? To stop ballots from being counted.
Ballots which were increasingly going for Andrew
Gillum. Trump is either casually admitting to
using federal agencies to interfere in a state
election, or for some reason he's making it up and
lying about it, which makes him even more depraved
and unhinged. Which one do you think that it is?
How is this an allegation that the Department
of Justice doesn't follow up on using federal
agencies to interfere with a state election that
you see is turning against the way you want it to
go? Is it to stop the ballot counting? Is it to
ensure only certain ballots are counted? What is
it that Trump is even claiming that he did? And
even if the scenario is Trump's lying and making
this up, there is almost always a grain of truth
to some of these things. What did Donald Trump do?
We have no idea, but he appears to be admitting to
criminality. Now, there's another aspect to this
that's important to consider as well. Notice that.
When it comes to the search warrant at Mar a Lago.
I know some of you know exactly where I'm going
with this with the Mar a Lago search warrant.
Trump's criticism and the criticism of Steve
Bannon and HANNITY and all of these people,
the criticism is. The Biden administration is
using the FBI as a political tool. The Biden
administration is politicizing and weaponizing
what's supposed to be a law enforcement agency.
It doesn't appear that that's what's happening.
Everything was done 100% correctly when it comes
to the search warrant. But what Donald Trump
is saying is I'm actually the one who did it.
I politically used the FBI to go into Florida.
And I guess he's saying the stop the vote,
the vote count that was turning in Andrew
Gillum favor. It is insane the degree to
which these allegations end up being confessions.
This one just took a little while when it came to
summer of 2020. They are going to try to steal an
election they don't win. Talking about Democrats,
well, within just a couple of months, we
figured out, oh, Trump was going to try to
steal an election that he didn't actually
win. The allegation was a confession about
what they were going to do. And there's been
numerous examples of this. Oh, Hillary Clinton
isn't going to safeguard and properly handle
classified and sensitive documents. Well,
it took a few years, but we figured out,
oh, actually, it's Trump who wasn't going to
safeguard and seriously handle those documents.
That allegation was also a confession. And now.
Since Joe Biden became president and in
particular since the search warrant was
executed at Mar a Lago. Oh, this is a this is a
presidency that is politicizing and weaponizing
the FBI against political opponents. Trump seems
to be admitting to having done exactly that.
In favor of his then ally, Ron DeSantis,
and against the political opponent,
Andrew Gillum. Another allegation which
appears to be a confession or Trump is
just lying about the fact that he committed
a crime. If Trump did this, it is illegal.